what will the cars of the future look
like for decades car companies and
reporters have tried to predict what
kind of vehicles we'd be driving
although some of these ideas may have
come up short what about the new buzz
around the driverless car driverless
cars will be a fact of life sooner
rather than later port CEO mark fields
says that in five years the company will
be manufacturing fully autonomous
vehicles uber is already running
self-driving taxis on an experimental
basis in Pittsburgh and Google for years
has been experimenting with a fully
autonomous car in California but is all
that just a lot of hype and how will it
change infrastructure projects and
transportation policy this is completely
absurd that's Bob Poole the Searle
freedom trust transportation fellow and
director of transportation policy at
Reason Foundation he sat down with
recent TVs editor-in-chief Nick
Gillespie to answer a few questions
about the future of autonomous vehicles
so you're more skeptical about
driverless cars than most people you
know and that they'll they'll become
fully autonomous cars will become the
norm on American roads in a short period
of time where's your skepticism coming
from skepticism is coming partly from
researchers serious researchers not not
reporters writing in the popular press
at UC Berkeley at Carnegie Mellon at MIT
who say this is a much harder problem
than a lot of people including Elon Musk
make it out to be I think from the point
at which true autonomous driving as
possible which which I think it's
probably in the five or six year time
frame you said that before though yeah
it's easy to get a car to self Drive on
an interstate where it has very few odd
situations to have to cope with but in
ordinary driving on congested city
streets with construction zones and a
thrown ball darting up the road this is
a very hard
artificial intelligence problem to solve
and it has to be done in an extremely
reliable way I mean I'm thinking of
myself I spend a lot more time driving
on city you're right if it's right
exactly so that's the majority of time
at least maybe not the majority of miles
with the majority of time that's a much
harder problem the head of Google axis
autonomous vehicle project was quoted
saying that this problem for all kinds
of driving purposes in all kinds of
environments is orders of met several
orders of magnitude
it made order magnitudes a 10 to 10 fold
in
so hundred or thousand times more
complicated than driving on the
interstate so I guess people like Elon
Musk they can afford to just buy new
children or trees and things like that
right the first self-driving car won't
be a car and more drivers trucking is
really for long-haul truck where they're
having a huge problem retaining drivers
the driver turnover in long-haul
trucking is a hundred percent per year I
don't think there's any industry that
has higher turnover at least for people
that are making that kind of money and
so this is really a problem this huge
problem of fatigue it's getting worse
because the federal hours of service
regulations mean that they have to get
eight hours of uninterrupted off time
rest for after a certain amount of
driving so long-haul corridors with
probably with dedicated truck lanes
where you can have autonomous or
semi-autonomous trucks initially semi
autonomous platoons of trucks where you
get five to ten percent fuel savings by
two or three of them taking advantage of
close spacing and less overall drag that
that means the fuel consumption is less
even if there is a you know driver or an
autonomous or semi-autonomous long-haul
truck it's gonna stop and then it's
going to get turned over you're good and
you're gonna need a driver to be making
deliveries picking up and dropping off
stuff and so forth I think for a long
long time
widespread adoption of shared
self-driving vehicles could render
parking spots and driveways obsolete and
transform urban landscapes one of the
things driving the dream of the
driverless car the autonomous car or
like a an uber system which relies on
robots even more so than right people is
yeah is is the idea that you know look
what you know we own cars and we barely
use them even if we're driving to work
four hours a day each way you know we've
got 20 hours we're not what what's wrong
with that argument well there's a lot of
sociological reasons that we don't know
how to assess for the long term but
people like the option value of having
the car always available when whenever
something occurs that you want the
mobility the idea of mobility as a
service replacing so shared vehicles
Robo taxis potentially could could
replace all personal vehicle travel
that's a huge debate within within the
AV community nobody has a clue what's
the percentage let's say once we have
fully full robo taxis that can go
anywhere anytime what fraction of people
will choose to own an autonomous vehicle
versus to use mobility as a service and
it's kind of like we don't I mean we
could everybody could rent or live in
hotels right and sometimes it would be
cheaper but yeah you want you want to
own it you want to personalize it you
want
so that unknown and all the honest
researchers say this could be ten
percent owned a 90 percent shared or
could be 90 percent owned and ten
percent share and we don't really have a
clue as to which way that's going to go
what are the implications of either
fully automated or semi-autonomous
transportation vehicles or options for
things like passenger rail and Amtrak
well I think the one of the biggest
impacts that's likely for autonomous
vehicles particularly the Robo taxi idea
is the vast disruption of today's Mass
Transit rail transit buses transit if
you have door-to-door trip possibilities
from our Robo taxi without the cost of
the driver which is the largest single
operating cost in any transit system
this up ends the whole apple cart and so
when I see places like Seattle the
voters just approved something a fifty
billion dollar plan to expand their
light rail over the next 30 years I mean
it well into the timeframe when we are
likely to have Robo taxis in at least
part of the transit market and
eventually the entire transit this is
completely absurd we'll leave it there I
want to thank Bob Poole director of
transportation policy in the Searle
freedom trust a fellow at Reason
Foundation thanking for a reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
[Music]